Fred after editing Django Unchained did
you think you'd be working with Quentin
Tarantino again I mean I I dreamed that
I would we got along really well on
Django so so I'm not gonna say that I
was surprised but you know I also don't
like to look a gift horse in the mouth
like it
it was Django was a terrific experience
a movie that I absolutely loved and and
getting to work with him was great so
when this movie started I hoped that I
would get the call and indeed I did and
I was thrilled to get it you did okay do
you remember the day that you got the co
completely well I mean I actually went
out to dinner with him or we went to a
Mexican restaurant for margaritas and
he's and he's like all right first
things first I want you to do the movie
so big hugs and and if followed by lots
of margaritas and Mexican food followed
by a Paul Mazursky double feature at the
New Beverly cinema so good way to kick
things off okay very nice yeah shots for
everybody yeah so we understand that
while editing the hateful eight that I
believe after every like last edit you
would blow it up to 70 millimeter so you
could watch it whine do it that way and
how how tough was that to have that
happen every time so so the movie was
shot on 70 millimeter film the we
screened the dailies the the work
picture on film at the end of every
shoot day and as we were editing as I
was working with Quentin at the end of
every day I would turn over the sequence
that we've been working on to my
assistants who would then conform the
the 70 millimeter work picture to match
my edit in the computer and we would
then screen that on a weekly basis
usually on Wednesday afternoon we'd go
to the DGA theatre theatre number one
and watch it projected on 70 millimeter
it's a beautiful theatre and it was
really inspiring I think I think when we
initially did it there might be some
concern that there was some concern that
maybe we're gonna see things in the
frame that we haven't seen on the avid
so like on the computer because it's
such a big frame that we need to be
aware if there's anything we should be
concerned about but what ultimately
ended up happening
is for the most part there wasn't a
whole lot of spotting things that we
hadn't seen it was more just feeling the
movie washing over us in 70-millimeter
was tremendously exciting and it really
inspired us to like to keep going it was
we were under some very tight time
constraints
and and it was such a pleasure to get to
do these screenings and see how great
this movie was turning out that yeah I
really helped keep us going was great
well I know with Django Unchained I
think he had you look at it on a little
monitor and I think you were you said
just jokingly with all due respect
please I would no no that wasn't Django
that was that was inglourious basterds
yes Quentin invited me to a rough-cut
screening oh come and and it was gonna
be on the avid and and and and when he
called I said to him you're putting me
in this terrible position because on the
one hand there's no movie that I want to
see more than inglorious basterds as it
as a Jewish guy a movie about Jews
killing Nazis like this is there could
it be a movie that's more up my alley
but I said on the one hand the III
couldn't be more sad to say on the other
hand you're asking me to watch it on a
35 inch standard-definition TV monitor
this is gonna be kind of painful and and
and he said to me I feel your pain but
know that you will actually potentially
have an opportunity to have an impact on
how the movie comes out and I said
truthfully you really think I was gonna
say no how much time were you given to
cut the hateful eight it's a really good
question I well I should really know the
answer to this m'as about four months
well sorry four months from the end of
production I was on the movie I like I
started editing the moment like on day
two of shooting so so so I was actually
on the movie from January through
I get I guess early November so that's
ten months right sounds like it's
something like huh huh yes so ten months
from beginning to end but that includes
the sound mix like we finished editing
the picture a month before of the the
the before we finished with the entire
process which was I think I want to say
the second week in November so is that
normal for especially a movie of this
length is that a normal timeframe faster
than normal
it's I you know what it's a little
faster than normal
mainly because the 70 millimeter of it
all because we're doing a 70 millimeter
film version they had to do a film
finish where the negative was cut and
the the the print was photochemically
color timed and they needed to make
prints and the lead time for that is I
think it's approximately six weeks so it
was six weeks less that we had time to
edit so it did crunch the schedule a bit
and and did up up the pressure that we
were under okay so your mentor and
Quentin Tarantino's former a longtime
editor Sally mink he had a quote where
she said it's all emotion impulsive and
instinctual just follow the characters
emotions do you believe in this
philosophy absolutely okay
and so when you're cutting and
especially with with a film with such
long takes and all the talent that
you're using how are you working with
the different edits because you had so
much to work with these different actors
but how are you how are you deciding you
know because of these long takes and how
long is too long
what's too short so it truthfully it
depended on the sequence it depended
what the sequence was trying to do if if
we had all of the actors in the frame at
at a given moment everyone who we wanted
to see we could hold as long as we
wanted to especially you know given
given the clarity of the image and and
so
so so the challenge really became
determining when it will be actually
effective to cut to something else but
you've seen the movie I have yes so so
the sequence that ends the first act of
the movie where major Warren tells
general Smithers what happened to his
son there that sequence is very specific
in terms of the editing style because
for reasons that will become clear at
the beginning of the next chapter we're
not seeing all of the characters in the
room we're really only seeing three
we're seeing major warren telling the
story we're seeing general Smithers
listening to it and we're seeing Chris
Mannix occasionally interjecting but and
I guess we see Bob at the piano but no
one else do we see because that's part
of the mystery that's gonna unfold at
the beginning of the second act of the
movie well there are any scenes that the
two of you felt were just too graphic
that you should be taken out nothing
that we felt should be taken out there
there was there was a little bit more to
the flashback section of the sequence
that I was just talking about the stuff
with major Warren and general Smithers
son where we had we had we used a little
bit more footage than you see in the
finished movie and we kind of felt like
we went a little bit too far here let's
let's pull this back a little but that's
really it as you're probably aware
having seen the movie we didn't hold
back too often no no I no spoilers I
don't want to give it away but yeah it
was pretty clear what was going on but
in making those decisions how much
deliberation are you going through I
mean are you really just kind of running
it by other people or just the two of
you in a guts an instinct and moment
just saying I think we'll cut that to be
honest with this movie we didn't really
have any of those sorts of issues where
we felt we'd gone too far with the
exception of the one thing they just
mentioned I think Quentin and I have
very similar senses of humor and we
frequently find ourselves cackling like
hyenas and at the most hideous of an
appalling violence in the movie as we're
putting the stuff
together so as long as we were amused it
was all good Django Unchained was a
different issue we did have stuff where
we had to pull back because there were a
couple of sequences in the movie that
were a little traumatizing to the
audience the the mandingo fight followed
about 15 minutes later by the scene
where d'Artagnan the slave is being
eaten by the dogs those were both really
rough sequences and it took the audience
something like 20 minutes to a half an
hour to recover from those sequences and
so with that movie we did we we cut
deeper than we had originally intended
to because we could feel that we'd lost
the audience because the sequences were
so effective with this movie we really
didn't have those concerns about
anything I don't doubt that there will
be people who will find the last scene
of act 1 to be traumatic but they also
have a built-in recovery time what would
the intermission so yeah there was
nothing really that beyond what I just
said where we had the hole back in
anyway what do you love about your job I
mean I get to work with a legendary
filmmaker who is one of my favorite
filmmakers who is incredibly gifted and
it is making exactly the kind of movie
that I want to go see I mean that to me
that that's I really consider myself to
be blessed I've gotten to work on so
many movies that are my favorite types
of movies I love westerns I've got to
work on two of them in the last year
this is you know it's it's it's a huge
thrill to get to do this and to get to
to get to craft these performances and
to help tell this story working with
this filmmaker that I have so much
respect for I mean I pinch myself on a
daily basis it's it's really an honor
when you look at the initial rough cut
that you've created it for the hateful
eight any other films you've worked on
how hard are you on yourself like how
much do you kind of cringe and then come
back to it refine it again more cuts or
are you pretty forgiving because you
know this is just the initial piecing
together um no I am NOT forgiving at all
because because I know if this is what
I'm going to be presenting to Quentin
Tarantino the first time he's going to
watch it okay
so III really I I really go above and
beyond to make the sequence the best
that I think it can possibly be and
there's there is nothing more
disheartening than when I've gone
through all of that trouble and Quentin
comes in and says actually I'd like to
do this this way and I and I look at him
like oh that's exactly how it should be
why the heck didn't I think of that in
the first place but but but by the same
token there's nothing more thrilling
than having him watch something that
I've done for the first time and just
like react with glee to every moment in
the sequence so it's I mean it's great
so it's kind of an emotional
rollercoaster ride only because you want
to turn out amazing work absolutely
right no I mean uh you can't okay
you can't afford to slack off when
you're working with a filmmaker of that
caliber absolutely what other editors
work do you admire like what other films
that you were just your favorite where
you just loved the certain cuts and how
they would dissolve a scene here or
there um there there are a lot of my go
to my go-to favorite editor is gonna be
Paul Hirsch who if you're not familiar
with his resume Star Wars blow out
Ferris Bueller's Day Off planes trains
and automobiles
Mission Impossible Mission Impossible 4
like he's he is absolutely brilliant
like and in an editor who clearly had a
great impact on the projects that he
took on I I really admire the work that
he's done and you know if I if my career
ends and I have a resume that is half as
impressive as his I would consider
myself to be a very lucky man what
advice would you have for someone
wanting to become an editor possibly
can't afford college maybe they would
just learn from watching YouTube videos
which I know there's a plethora of
information from children online that
you could just learn all sorts of
interesting little techniques where
would you suggest someone start and how
can they actually get in the business
and start either interning or working
that is a good question and it's a
tricky one to answer I mean obviously
the obviously they have like you learn
by doing so edit everything you can when
when I was in film school and I decided
that editing was what I wanted to go
into I made it a point to tell all my
friends that that I want to be an editor
this is what interests me the most and I
am and and so I started working with
their films and editing editing as many
films as I could when I then made my way
up the ranks as an assistant working for
selling thank-you for example she would
give me scenes in in like the movie all
the pretty horses that Billy Bob
Thornton directed she gave me some
scenes to cut and it was great that I
like I would I would do the work and I
would send it off to her and she would
evaluate it and call me and tell me this
I was on location in San Antonio while
she was in LA and she would give me her
thoughts on on the work that I'd done
and and tell me what she had done to it
and why she changes that she had made
and why she and why she'd made them and
it was very inspiring to me it kept me
going it it's something that now that
I'm in the editors chair I try to do
with my assistants because I I think
there's no question that it contributed
to me getting where I am in terms of how
to break into the business everybody
goes down a different path I can say
without question that I've worked with a
lot of people who didn't go to college
so going to film school is not
necessarily something that you need to
have done but but I found it very
helpful because I I established
relationships with my classmates that
led directly to me finding work
but you know when I was just first
starting out in Los Angeles the way
people would try to find work in
editorial if they didn't know anyone
literally you you there would be
facilities there are facilities that are
primarily editing houses and you would
just you'd walk around with a stack of
resumes and you'd knock on every door
and you'd see if someone would allow you
to talk to them for like 15 minutes in
hand a resume and maybe they would end
up needing someone at some point down
the line and that could lead to work
sometimes it did usually usually what
happened to me is that I was introduced
to one person in this industry a guy
named Bob Layton who was Rob Reiner as
editor I'd worked with a friend of his
when I was in New York and Bob
introduced me to his assistants and they
in turn made some introductions and and
and through that I managed to get my
first internship and as luck would have
it one of the people I worked with on
that internship got a job working on a
movie that was paying and and she asked
me to come aboard and help out as an
apprentice editor and that got me into
the Union and once I was in the Union I
became eligible for a lot more work and
through those same connections IIIi was
able to land my first Union job on the
picture Boogie Nights so but you know
everyone's path is different
sure last question just okay lastly why
editing when you were in film school why
not be the the DP why not why not
screenwriting why editing so everyone
goes to film school to become a director
and I had this realization about midway
through my my sophomore year at film
school that god there are a lot of
really talented people in my class and
the idea that all of us are going to get
directing gigs immediately upon
graduation this is a little ridiculous
so so perhaps I should focus on a craft
just in case this directing thing
doesn't work out and an editing was
always my favorite part of the process
because I feel it's the closest to
directing you are
you're telling the story visually you
are crafting the performances you and
you're doing it from the comfort of an
air-conditioned room and interestingly
enough at the time when I made the
decision editing was the the part of the
process that required the least
technical know-how because we were like
I learned how to edit on film we're
using a steam back a flatbed editing
system all you need to know was how to
thread it up and you could be an editor
being a cinematographer you had to
understand lighting and you had to
understand taking taking light meter
readings and film stocks you had to know
all of this stuff editing was really
just all about the art and it really
appealed to me and eyes that's what I
focused on and it's been very good to me